الى التداعيات المعيشيه للاشتباكات
المسلحه حيث قال مواطنون بمنطقه الافتتحاب
جنوب ام درمان للجزيره انهم يواجهون
صعوبات في الحصول على المواد الغذائيه
الاساسيه بعدما تسببت عملياتنا في وقف عمل
متاجر بالمنطقه بشكل كلي اشار المواطنون
الى ان سيارات تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع
نهبت متجرين على الطريق الرئيسي للحي مما
دفع اصحابهما لاغلاقهما فورا وفي الاثناء
تشهد منطقه الجريف شرقيه الخرطوم ازمه
حاده في الخبز بسبب توقف المطاحن عن امداد
المخابز بالدقيق
وبحسب اصحاب المخابز الذين تحدثوا للجزيره
فان المخابز لن تحصل على حصتها من الدقيق
منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات منتصف الشهر الماضي
ونبهوا الى ان مخزون الدقيق على وشك
النفاذ مما ينذر باسمى